I have a concern about Chris of critical
theory critic this this whole this
everything that's happening right now I
believe is a Trojan horse I believe that
that James Lindsay and how he described
it as the Trojan horse is he's exactly
right on it's coming into our churches
do the division that it's causing right
now is insane because like you said it's
another gospel it's another religion
it's like because once again they
haven't their own epistemology so the
way that they discover truth is is from
a positional standpoint so so how do I
respond to that I'm Dave Rubin and this
is the Rubin report quick reminder
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click that pesky
notification bell and joining me today
is an author and a teaching pastor
Nathan finocchio welcome to the Rubin
report hey it's good to be here I'm glad
to have you sir because as you probably
know I do some talking to people of
faith people better skeptics people that
are somewhere in between and I always
find these to be sort of the most
interesting conversations that I have so
before we do anything about what you're
doing now tell me a little bit about
your journey to fate yeah so I'm the son
of a preacher man my dad has been in the
ministry as long as I could remember and
I've sort of just fallen into it to be
quite honest I try to not necessarily
run the other way but do something else
and sort of just caught up to me you
know it's like you know so it's just
kind of this is what I do now because
it's just kind of right what I know but
I do I do you know have always had a
kind of strong faith in God I just never
saw myself as the ministerial type
because you know like people of faith I
guess spiritual leaders they kind of
happen a type my in my iminium they're
my opinion they're kind of square and
they stay home on Friday nights and play
Scrabble with Grandma and there's just
not what I wanted to do with my life you
know
hey don't knock Scrabble man everybody
loves Scrabble look I take that back
okay Scrabble is great and grandma's
wonderful well to your point though you
kinda it's like well wait a minute look
at this guy he doesn't really look like
a pastor and then on the other hand you
look like sort of a modern Jesus so
you're you're sort of doing a little
everything over there um it's you know
it's a work in progress did you on the
way you said you did a little something
before going into this even though you
came from a family of faith what was the
faith part always there or did you mean
that you deviated from that too or did
you just mean that sort of career-wise
or something else I just think that sort
of career-wise yeah I was doing music
for about eight years and so oh yeah
it's kind of doing that and things just
didn't work out the way I kind of wanted
them to work out nice for went back to
went back to the family farm so to speak
and so I'm just kind of doing ministry
now for the last gosh I don't know last
six years
so if somebody said you sort of lay out
what your belief system is what would
that be kind of broadly speaking yeah so
I'm I'm a confessional Christian that's
what I'd say I'm in the kind of the
brand of Christianity that I'm or the
stream that I flow in it's more of a
Pentecostal Christianity you know so
we're the ones that I mean I've never
handled a snake before but that's what
kind of what meta Gospels are known for
you know tambourine destroying
Pentecostals we're the ones that when
you go to our churches on the weekend
it's kind of like a rock concert so
we've got lasers and you know we kind of
attract a younger crowd but our idea
basically is that we have a a historic
Orthodox confessional Christian doctrine
so we believed that the stuff that the
church has always believed and we
confess and we profess that but we wrap
it up in sort of a modern in a modern
vibe yeah do you get a lot of pushback
on that sort of I've seen this in a few
different versions where there's you
know the sort of belief that you just
have to have the belief in the the
orthodoxy and and the conservative look
at religion and then you bring in music
you bring in lasers you bring in bands
and all sorts of other stuff and people
a certain set of people will think that
that will kind of erode the original
message yeah
yeah I think that's utter and total
ridiculousness basically I mean look at
Vatican three and kind of what the
Catholic Church is done like is having
services in English somehow diminish the
Catholic churches you know their their
message no it doesn't so that's
essentially what we're doing where
whereas they're just there for them
progress is translating the math from
Latin to English for us we're doing
exactly that we're translating the
message but like you know the currency I
think of our generation is music and the
arts and so that's kind of how we we
communicated that language right so sort
of speaking of music in the arts will
kind of put you on my radar is that
Justin Bieber is a member of the church
I don't want you to get into any any
specifics about anyone that goes to the
church but but what do you sense is
happening with people of his age related
to belief there does seem to be
something going on you know Kanye's
running these services now and you know
as you just said it's sort of related to
music and culture and something else
it's not what we think of when we just
think of like the traditional religious
perspective
yeah hundred percent I think that people
I know you mentioned Justin and Kanye as
far as I know they had church upbringing
so there's a lot a lot of people come up
in the church I know Justin for a fact
it I went to I I spoke at his home
Church in Canada I'm actually Canadian I
I grew up 45 minutes from where he grew
up so I know like I mean Elvis for
crying out loud you know came up in the
churches it's not uncommon in the
American story the people in the arts
come up in church and then they kind of
leave the small town and they go do big
musical things so but in terms of a
return I mean we saw it even in Elvis's
career you know the only album they'd
ever won a Grammy for was for his gospel
record so there's something I think
intrinsic to Americana
and the church and music so it's a
pretty common common theme YP you know
Millennials and Gen Z's are weak or
reconnecting with the church or
connecting for the first time to faith I
think large in part due to the failure
you know perhaps of of secularism it
doesn't work and there's questions I
think that that it's attempted to answer
that it hasn't answered and that's why
you'll even see guys like Sam Harris who
have become spiritual not in any sort of
Orthodox sense but an awareness that
maybe there is something out there that
aren't we connect to and soul and spirit
etc so I think we have something to
offer people that is that is reasonable
and that is also experiential
so one of the things that I've been
talking about on the show a lot lately
is that I think a lot of the problems
we're having is that we seem to be
reaching the end of secularism which i
think is sort of what you're alluding to
that when you get to the end of pure
secularism with nothing else outside of
itself that everything's on the table
again and we don't know if men are men
and women are women and we're debating
destroying you know our past in the name
of some utopian future and the rest of
it do you see that as just like the
natural kind of outgrowth of what of
what a purely secular society is yeah I
think gosh you know without getting into
a huge history lesson well what I would
call I think there's two types of
there's two types of people in our
churches right now okay there's we what
we would make might call leftists and a
secular might be a secularist might be a
better term but and then we have you
know for lack of a better term a
conservative which I can't stand the
term but but just using generalizations
and what I think has happened as a
society is that we have an
epistemological crisis that's kind of
what happened with what has happened
because secularism is the idea
essentially that material is the only
thing that you can touch and we get all
we don't live together in our material
society and let's forget about things
that are not are non material like
spirituality because those things will
just divide us and it kind of be kind of
works out at first but then it begins to
hammer down everybody into just material
and people aren't just material and the
world isn't just material there's a lot
more to it than that and so we have this
epistemology that's kind of developed
from secularism and that this term ology
is essentially like when you when we got
rid of
of traditional authority which you know
patrician authorities like Kings and you
know that the priests and church and not
that they weren't
you know commit like doing bad things
and that there was reason for them to
for us to be suspicious of it and so we
did away with it it's sort of like now
that we have no traditional authority
the self has become the locus of of
everything like so we're the locus of
interpretation and so there's a great
deal of pressure on people to know
everything that's why I like in our
culture we have yet you have to self
authenticate you have to self-help you
need to build up the cell and you need
to be the best version of yourself
because nobody out here is gonna help
you and you can't trust anybody and so
what happens is that experience now
becomes like it becomes the highest
metric in a world where there's no
authorities that can be trusted and so
in the church we have people that are
coming in and right look they're like
it's all about experience and so that's
I think where that we're you know borrow
from James Lindsay that's where a
positional epistemology becomes so
massive and we have we're dealing with
it with churches right now so it's like
you know people love the idea of Jesus
but the the scriptures to which so
Christians we appeal to an external
authority we believe that we believe
things about reality that that that are
just kind of they're incompatible with
most kids that are coming in like kids
that are coming in or going reality is
my experience but Christianity is going
reality is what God says in the
scriptures and so that's it's kind of
it's and it's very similar to that's why
I think the Christianity will save
Western civilization because we might be
the last ones who believe in science
which would be hilarious so but just the
idea that yet we believe that that truth
exists externally like imagine that that
that religious fanatics believe that
truth exists externally Dave right we
believe in what we might call
phenomenological transcendence the idea
that like a tree isn't you can't just
call a tree whatever you want to call a
tree you know a tree is real and if you
want to go ahead and drive your car into
that tree you will experience
phenomenological transcendence you will
experience that but rather why don't you
live your life like there are things
that
exist outside of you and for us as the
way that we appeal to Christians and we
try to you know kind of try to convert
them to Christianity because to be in it
Christianity is this thing that's like
we it's reasonable we believe the truth
it's external it's not all about you and
your experiences it's also about some
things that you know that God has said
and his word and so morality isn't just
kind of whatever you want it to be or
however you want to paint it it's you
know God who created you he has some
opinions he's God it is what it is and
so you need to you know does it make
sense so it's an episiotomy war that the
church is in yeah you gave me about five
roads there that we could shoot off of
so I'm gonna I'm gonna try to come
around to all of them or get them into
substitute with the earth what I'll see
if I can do it but first you mentioned
James Lindsay who I've had on the show
of course who wrote the book with with
Peter Bogosian about how to have
important conversations one of the
things that I'm sort of amazed by by the
sort of James Lindsay Peter Bogosian
Michael Shermer the more I would say
left-leaning largely atheist crew is
that many of them are suddenly going you
know all those religious people we were
screaming about they're not so bad and
they're appearing on stage with
religious people they're you know I
don't know if you know but just about
six or eight months ago I was on stage
in front of 14,000 students at Liberty
University with Jerry Falwell Jr right
next to me and it was just absolutely
incredible and sure we have some
differences we have some theological
differences we have some you know
spiritual differences and political
differences but no nobody cared
everybody was thrilled it was wonderful
but I'm curious what you think about
that the fact that some of the sort of
main drivers of secularism are suddenly
looking at you guys basically and going
oh you're you're a lot nicer than that
other crew over there right yeah I don't
think it's just modern intersectional
ISM that we're strange bedfellows I
think that we have a very similar pistol
malla G and that's why we actually argue
Dave you you can't argue with people
that you don't have the same
epistemology with
we have the same epistemology as
atheists like we we do have demands of
we have different mans of literature and
we come at things believing that there
are external forces to feel the
difference being that an atheist would
believe in in a strictly material
universe but but material it is super
important to Christians as well and the
idea that truth lives externally is it's
really important to us as well so I
think that yeah and we find ourselves on
the same aisle with respect to where
epistemology and you know this about I
mean Christians aren't perfect and you
know we've slammed in our thousands and
we've made some massive mistakes and one
of my favorite quotes of a Christian
theologian is st. Augustine who said
that the church is a [ __ ] but she's my
mother
we're a we're Dave of the things that
have happened in history that are stupid
there's a lot of people who have used
the scripture to do some really stupid
things
but yet we find ourselves now you know
debating with people who we have the
same epistemology we can't I can't have
a conversation with you if you can't
define reality the way that I define
reality and so to me once again it's an
epistemological factor
do you sense young people that are that
are showing up now sure that the lights
and the music is something and and
you're explaining sort of the end of
secularism so they feel that there's a
hole there but do you do you sense just
like in the last couple years maybe
because of the cultural war because of
social media that the hole that they
have seems to be way bigger that it's
maybe not just spiritual but it's also
very community-based you know we got all
of these tools and apps and we thought
it was gonna make us more connected and
in many ways social media made us
antisocial and now people are trying to
find community in oddly more traditional
ways whether there's lasers or not right
yeah absolutely I remember there's a
book written in the 90s by guiding
platinum and talk the title of Bowling
Alone and it sort of was a sociological
book just looking at the erosion of
community in America you know beginning
with the bowling leagues you know how
like bowling leagues were like they
replaced Church for you know my
grandfather's generation and and now
yeah that's gone
so there's definitely there's definitely
a sociological factor I think that to be
quite honest with you the sociological
factor may very well be one of the the
biggest factors in the church we're all
we understand the value of community we
believe theological II that were not
made to be alone there was one thing in
the garden that was wrong a lot of
people think that you know in that
Genesis story that God creates this
garden it's it's like it's perfect it's
paradise was not it was optimal for
living and the one thing that was wrong
was that Adam was alone and so you know
he creates Eve and and so were created
for one another and we need one another
desperately so that's definitely a tenet
of our faith and there's definitely a
sociological bit factor to church and
yeah there's a giant well I also believe
that
there's this there's this book written
by a Pulitzer Prize winner I think his
name is Ernest Becker the title of it
was the denial of death and he was in
his book he sees Negus and he sort of
this looking at secularism and kind of
what it's done in in modernity and he
believes that laughing with the death of
God society becomes sort of was just
like okay well now I because I I need
some money to validate my reality to
validate my existence to see me because
we need to be seen as human beings and
that's why we need relationship and so
he believed that the first option that
modern stride was the love option in
that you know and that's why everybody
talks about having the one finding the
want like like 300 years ago like love
wasn't the reason why you got married
you know like but now we put all this
emphasis and that's why we have
apocalyptic hookup culture you know in
New York because we're all all trying to
find God you know him and for somebody
to validate your living so to me that's
what the church are you saying are you
saying God's not on tinder is that what
you're telling me oh he's definitely on
tinder he's definitely searching for
people he's going after the knees left
of 99 and going after the one so I think
that I think that what you said is
absolutely right and a roundabout way I
think that you know we're looking for
love we're looking for romance and I
think we've you know in you know in a
strange way we do find it in community
we find that validation that we need but
but in a in a more spiritual sense Dave
yeah we found we find it in God and that
he and that's what I believe that's what
we teach we teach that God for one who
sees you he's the one who goes after you
you're not the one who's been going
after him but he's been the one that's
been pursuing you because he knows you
he knows how to get to you and he loves
you and for so when people sort of when
that settles them there's a lot of
things in their life that
and being a part of a community is
definitely one of them yeah
so before you mention the sort of lefty
verse conservative demographics that
you're dealing with in the church so as
we've watched this culture war just like
explode all over the place I know that
all sorts of churches temples at
virtually every organization secular or
not is dealing with some sort of like
internal split over how to deal with
everything that's happening these days
literally from coronavirus to black
lives matter and everything in between
what what version of that are you seeing
these days
yeah there's definitely a political
part of everything I mean dude this is
insane
like it's insane I keep on telling my
friends is I'm sure that all your
friends going what is happening in 2020
you know for others that there's a
there's a conversation in the church
right now politically about the
threshold of
threshold of religious liberty versus
you know government needing to you know
keep tabs and a lid on coronavirus and
so we're kind of I guess exploring that
threshold you know you got people who
that's that's it that's that absolutely
fine falls along ideological lines right
so there's there's seems like there's
two types of Americans there's ones that
want to they have a huge trust in the
government my wife is one of them my
wife is an Australian I'm a Canadian but
my wife is like she trusts the
government she's just like they are you
know they love us
and I want to meet she told me last
night she's like I want to be nannied
I'm like my aha moment they're just like
okay have you luck with all of that
totally
so they're you got my my wife jasmine
and then you got me and I'm like the
most
distrusting you know person of
government because yeah you know like
they who are these angels you know like
the old argument were these angels that
are gonna make all these right decisions
for us so there's that that's a huge
conversation of the church and that
alone Dave was tearing us apart
right like so you got like pastors like
calling up pastors and people call
enough people or like in the in the
faith community just being like you need
to trust the covering authorities from
God and then
and then now you have of course you know
George Floyd's death which was horrific
and tragic and you have black lives
matter the organization that's kind of
occupied some space
in wake of the George Floyd killing and
then Ahmad Harbury because it looks it
looks
social media that young black men are
being hunted down and killed so so yeah
you have this major space and it's this
is another thing that's kind of dividing
us right now it's just like the
narrative to believe and and what we
ought to do about it and and regardless
of if you if you believe that narrative
or not you know Christians are called to
mourn with those who mourn and weep with
those who weep so finding the threshold
of going okay I might not agree with the
political narrative but I'm called to to
stand alongside you know people who are
in my life that regardless of whether I
know whether or not I believe that they
are their emotions are rooted in any
kind of reality and I'm arguing from a
you know if you're a conservative you
know like I have a responsibility
towards them to love them you know like
my wife is is terrified of airplanes
it's not rooted into anything logical at
all but I'm the one that's stuck pulling
the bag and comforting her and getting
her xanax when we're on a flight and you
know so there's an element of that if
you're a conservative that you have a
responsibility towards the people that
you're in community with and you're
living life with and you know you know
quoting stats and my wife doesn't help
her flight anxiety you know like right
so finding how well you know is the mess
right walk yeah how worried are you
though that letting in this sort of
different what I would call a religious
belief system social justice that once
it enters the institution enters the
church that in many ways it will just it
will rot from the inside all of the good
things that you've been talking about I
mean this is what we've sort of seen
happen to every secular institution it's
happening to the New York Times it's
happening to the Washington Post it's
happening to Harvard and Princeton and
all of our liberal institutions so I'm
sort of fascinated where with this idea
that it could be entering you know sort
of conservative or religious
institutions and that they may not even
have the correct defense mechanisms to
purge it or keep it at bay that's that's
exactly what's happening
so it's not necessarily so for me I've
tried to dance this line we're like you
know the idea of black lives matter it's
like it's an idea it's a saying I've
sort of divorced it from the
organization they don't like that but
I've divorced it from the organization
because you know yeah black lives do
matter and so if there are instances
where you know there's police brutality
that doesn't seem to fit you know the
resident I mean you know as we as we
examine the data that's one of the big
ones we know that that you know the
Harvard Rowland's his paper and we know
like this study that was done Heather
McDonald obviously lays this all out but
one of the things that I have a giant
question mark over is the police
brutality part I don't know if we're
nailing that you know well and so let's
say that you're like me where you're
going okay that the shooting part you
know there's there's no racial biases
that's been detected by three major
studies but please brutality do you have
a question on that like why are 30
percent of blacks being you know accused
of resisting arrest are they resisting
or is that what's happening or the
police you know being antagonistic not
towards them or whatever so so let's
let's just say for example that there is
some antagonism it needs to be dialed
back so I stand with my brother who
feels he's terrified okay and he's and
he's like Nate you know like I just feel
like block size of matter okay man black
lives matter okay I'm with you black
lives like I'll say that now the
organisation they believe in the dude
utilization of the family which is doing
nobody a service particularly the black
community in America right so so so for
me obviously I have some fat or
theological concerns to fry but I'm
walking this line where I'm in community
with with with with my black brothers
and sisters and so so for me like once
again
I have a concern about critical critical
theory critic this this whole this
everything that's happening right now I
believe is a Trojan horse I believe that
that James Lindsay and how he described
it as the Trojan horse is he's exactly
right on it's coming into our churches
do the division that it's causing right
now is insane because like you said it's
another gospel
it's another religion it's like because
once again they haven't cut their own
epistemology so the way that they
discover truth is is from a positional
standpoint so so how do I respond to
that it's it's it's it's almost an
impossible dance but I have to show
rational compassion not empathy because
empathy is you know as we've seen him in
the last like 10 15 years in psychology
is dangerous and your biases come into
empathy I have to have what's called
rational compassion so I have to
reasonably move through the data move
through the things that are happening
using my Christian worldview and frame
and framework in my epistemology you
know and go and then as I'm checking
these leaf movements and going okay
these are thundermans right
everything has a demand we demand that
know that you overhaul us James says you
know you can't tear down the Masters
house the Masters tools so we have to
completely change how we structure not
not just with the way we structure our
church organization but we also demand
that like the way that you go about
finding truth changes as well and so at
that point for me I'm not gonna fight
peripherals like in any good argument
you always argue first principle so you
don't argue peripherals and so for me
when it comes to the black lives matter
movement when it comes to the things
that are happening on the streets of the
protests etcetera I'm not gonna there
are some things I think that are
peripheral and as conservatives we get a
little bit sidetracked by and so to me
the critical theory thing and this is
why I think James Lindsay
is just so on the money right now is
because it's the you don't go after the
fruit you go after the root and to meet
critical theory is the root of this
giant problem it's it's the reason why
the political narrative has been spun
the way it is and so to me that's that's
what I'm going after while holding the
hand of people that are hurting yeah I
mean it's it's almost an impossible
place to put yourself because you're
trying to hold something you're trying
to be open you're trying to retain ideas
and and also not put people down it's
tough what do you make of this idea so
you hit on that that critical theory
whatever your cultural Marxism whatever
you want to call this thing that it's
religious in nature one of the one of
the facets that I'm constantly amazed by
is there's no forgiveness in this thing
that basically if you're white or you're
cisgendered or you're Christian or
whatever you're privileged and thus bad
and that really you just have to pay
penance your whole life you have to live
on your knees your whole life
where most religions have some level of
forgiveness right you can actually atone
for your sins and hopefully be a better
person on the other side this thing
doesn't have that this thing has oh well
live like a slave forever in effect but
a hundred percent so so in in critical
theory you're sort of guilty you know
before proven innocent
so everybody's guilty and as James
Lindsay he has observed and in his
findings all of the critical theorists
believe essentially that if you won't
even even you know for example I want to
be somebody accused me of problematic a
yesterday
but that's the whole point the whole
point is that I can never be truly an
ally my ally ship is always going to be
problematic there's you know like so
there's no there's no there's no end to
it it just continues to be what it is so
yeah they they don't forgive because
there's nothing to forgive because I'm
stuck and I'm stuck in the oppressor
group if I'm stuck in the oppressor
group and there's no escaping it
there can be no forgiveness if there's
no repentance right like isn't that how
it works so then I'm just perpetually a
sinner and I'm just gonna continue to
perpetuate the oppressor group and
there's nothing that I can do yeah
so that's why of course cancel culture
is actually the logical conclusion of
critical theory right it's the logical
conclusion that to be consistent
logically they have to be consistent in
their cancel culture because they have
to get rid of the oppressor class I hate
to tell you I think it's beheading this
is the logical conclusion cancel course
just cancel culture is just a stop on
the way but we could sort of leave that
just for you personally dealing with
this the idea that everything's become
political and in many ways I think
people used to go to have religious
experiences regardless of the religion
they would go there to escape politics
that that religion sort of offered them
that you know that separation from the
real world to to think of something
timeless something like that to see it
all seep in just for you as a leader of
a community how's that been on you
yeah so so so one of the things that I
do in my role is I travel to a number of
churches I don't I'm like I'm not the
lead pastor in a community but I go to
all of the different communities and I
speak at a number of churches and so
what is it what is it like well
yeah people are people don't get church
is supposed to be a place where they
like hear about the love of God for them
and they hear about the sacrifice that
you know it and then they remember the
Lord's passion etc and so it's kind of
become in some circles in some churches
the gospel has totally become about
current events and I think that that's
definitely problematic
you know it definitely become
problematic where where in Christianity
we teach essentially that everybody's a
priest in fact the Protestant
Reformation happened because one of you
know Martin Luther's 95 problems with
the Catholic Church was that you had to
have a priest to connect with God and
the New Testament is replete with
scriptures about the priesthood of the
believer and so what this necessarily
means for Protestants like me is that
every believer is supposedly coming to
church to be a priest that's what you
literally diffuse you come to and what
priests do they ministered the Lord they
minister to others but like when you
come to church and it's a lesson on
critical theory you know and there's
like there's no escape I think that
people aren't able to do their job as a
Christian I think that it's really tough
to glorify God or to worship God when
it's like you're in a perpetual
classroom and there's just down there's
confusion and and I think that one of my
biggest frustrations for me is that I
don't think that a lot of church leaders
have their pulse on this epistemological
issue so it's just it's washing it like
pastors are good people and they love
people and so from that good place of
going I love people they're probably
going we need to talk about this because
this is a real this is this is this is
where the rubber hits the road but
problematically if you're not even if
you're the pulse on culture and
understand and the undercurrents
epistemologically
you know you're creating a lot of
confusion for people so that's
absolutely what's happening
do you think certain religious
denominations and certain sex with in
religions are just better at keeping
some of this stuff at bay so it seems to
me it's not perfect but like something
like Orthodox Jews let's say have really
kept this at bay in a way that
conservative or reformed Jews haven't
been able to or evangelicals I think
have done a pretty good job at keeping
it at bay do you think that there are
like certain strengths and weaknesses
from a Protestant perspective or or
another denomination perspective that
makes certain worldviews a little more
able to stand up to these things
absolutely so it's a focus it's a focus
on on their purpose
like why does or why do Orthodox Jews
exist right like they know why and he
mean look right down sometimes to the
way that they dress like they're in this
world but they're not on this world sort
of as Jesus said and so I think that
that they do a great job you know of
like focusing on their community and
focusing on the reasons why they exist
so there's a there's definitely a
balance to be sure we'll see when I look
at Jesus and it's once again this is an
epistemological issue but when I look at
Jesus I don't look at somebody who is
necessarily engaged the politics of his
day I think that you know Jesus said My
Kingdom is not of this world and so he
had a little bit of but I'm in the world
but I'm not of it does that mean that we
don't engage in issues of justice no
doesn't mean that we don't I think that
marching with Martin Luther King was the
right thing to do during the civil
rights and and
you know I think that defeating Hitler
was probably a good thing to do you know
like so there's there's I think that the
church doesn't run from things but it's
it's finding its sifting through the
things that we should engage it how is
you engage and the threshold of that and
it's a conversation that we're having
right now and uh yeah evangelicals
probably have done a really great job
because evangelicals are a bit more
heady Pennock offices are probably a bit
more we lean a bit more experiential and
so I'm a that's you know I I wish that
Pentecostals you know we're a bit more
like evangelicals and in that day they
sifted they had their you know like
albert Mohler you know he he's the the
president of the Southern Baptist
Convention and he set out he sent out a
letter on critical theory to all of the
pastors and hey guys this is what's
happening like but Pentecostalism is a
bit of the Wild West and Christianity I
don't know if he knew this but we've
only been around for a hundred twenty
years and we there's 750 million of us
and were the fastest-growing version of
Christianity in the world like we're
gonna eclipse we're gonna eclipsed
Catholicism in 50 years so so hard brand
of Christianity in terms of filling
stadiums and people singing our songs
and all the stuff it's a it's it's a big
place and it's like it is the
battleground for Christian expression
and that finding that threshold of where
politics are what Christianity is going
to look like etc so Pentecostals don't
we don't have we don't have like a grand
Pumbaa like an albert Mohler or like a
Jerry vowel or whatever who
kind of dictates to us or will tell us
hey guys this is what's coming
independent so because of that was the
nature of that and because we're so
experiential and because we're so kind
of up on the culture
it's a mess right now but nobody knows
what to believe but we know that people
are hurting and so we're gonna run
towards people because we're
experiential people are having these
experiences so we're gonna love them but
that the rational part of our compassion
seems to be a bit missing and we're
unawares to what is really inside this
Trojan horse yeah well that's why
exactly why I wanted to have this
conversation because I just see this
happening across the board and I'm
fascinated when I see it in communities
that I'm not necessarily part of it's
incredible so when you see things like
you're in California to our wonderful
progressive governor Gavin Newsom you
know basically telling people that they
can't sing in church because that can
spread you know kovat and then you know
our mayor here in LA Garcetti is out
there with no mask on kneeling in front
of protesters and then also tells us we
can't have 4th of July celebrations or
you know we got to stay in our house all
of these just crazed conflicting
messages do you think that also is just
a driver for religion like it seems like
they're specifically attacking religion
at some level right you see de Blasio
locking up playgrounds for Orthodox Jews
to kids to go to but then he's out there
in the streets with protesters that
there seems to be like an actual assault
on religion and then at the same time
it's like everything they send us his
mixed messages so it's like a that's a
little paranoid ya know I think that
you're right to be honest with you I
feel like it's been open season on Jews
for some time now and it I think that
that's definitely there's a that falls
along a particular political aisle um
whether we care to admit it or not with
respect to Christians and houses of
worship
yeah like we Americans believe in
peaceful assembly and the right to
assemble and you know freedom of
religion and so there's once again you
know there's exploring that threshold of
who you can tell to that together you
know for example like a popular pastor
down here in California Jensen Franklin
made a statement about this on his
social media three days ago
and like all hell broke loose and
Pentecostal of Christendom and Benson
was just like hey like I feel like this
is a bit arbitrary and I'm telling
churches that we can image ensign
marched with protesters and he goes look
I March so I you know I was there and
what I'm saying though is I think it's
arbitrary to allow people to protest and
not a lot of people to sing in church
and it's just it's a pallet themes that
seems rational to me that seems bright
sensible hundred but you're saying on
everyone operates infinitum people
screaming right like so like if you can
scream in a mask right beside somebody
or you can stay in a mask you know
people go it's about droplets yet one
percent but that's what people do people
are screaming so I was like so I just
think that like the concern about Cove
in nineteen in some ways is like a
little bit it's miss I have so many
friends who had gone with 19 right like
you have a ninety eight point eight
percent chance of surviving this thing
if you're under the age of forty a so
like but it's all it all seems to be
young people young progressives who are
you know screaming at Jensen a young
Christian progressives going you know
how dare you bring the protesters into
this you know I'm not I marched but
don't you see this is a bit arbitrary
and then he said and then he said you
know make sure that you vote your faith
this this fall and that was the straw
them rub the camel's back so it's just
like you know you know you telling us to
vote now and who to vote for and I don't
know do this it's it's a mess and but I
think that well once again I think it
doesn't fall along necessarily faith
lines but it would fall along
ideological lines in terms of what type
of government
do you want do you want a government
that is overreaching or if you want a
government who is going to just allow
churches and allow for people to do what
they want to do and no I mean as far as
I know Dave hasn't it been that every
single High Court has ruled that these
governor's overreach of churches has
been unconstitutional is that correct I
don't know if it's every single one but
I've seen several of them yeah they're
directly I mean they should look we have
a Fourth Amendment we have the right to
assemble so the idea that Newsom saying
you can't do it in church but you can do
it on the streets it's simply not
constitutional yeah so I think that I
think that this type of stuff will
galvanize galvanize a particular brand
of Christian Christians but once again
in Pentecostalism you know our
epistemology is has already kind of been
experienced Olympus ition all our church
definitely is split right down the line
in terms of how people will vote how
people see like like my wife my wife
wants to be nannies god bless her I
don't so you see that we have some
serious you know I'm married to her okay
so like we have some series we have some
fat fish to fry
right then I only got one more for you
because we've talked about sort of the
strife and everything that's got us here
and everything else but as a man of
faith in a crazy time that we're in give
me something hopeful if you got it
what you know sort of an outlook that
gets us past this and and how do we get
to something that will start feeling a
little more maybe well maybe feeling
isn't the right word that will create a
reality that will be a little more in
line with some of the things that we've
talked about here that are the good bit
so I think that there are only cross
Christians believe that Jesus is gonna
come back and he is going to rule it
right on the earth forever that's that's
what we believe so until that happens I
think that there's gonna continue to be
chaos I'd now God has given us we
believe in this doctrine called common
grace where we believe that God has
given meant faculty and reason and I
believe that one of the ways that we
could limit the effects of the fall and
the effects of sin and the effects of
brokenness is by limiting government so
yeah like what is what is the hope for
things to maybe get better ultimately
the return of Christ and the gospel you
know that God that God will heal the
world and when he heals the world then
he becomes president there's no more
elections his his government will be so
good that'll be cause for praise
eternally until that happens I think
that limiting people's ability is
probably our greatest hope so yeah I
don't think that the Scriptures
necessarily paint some sort of utopian
you know let's bring the kingdom down to
earth right now before Jesus comes back
and this the Scriptures aren't
redemptive necessarily that way in terms
of things are going to get better things
probably will get worse just be just
knowing humanity humanity needs a Savior
the world is broken and
that we can all agree about that but I
don't think the fix is more people the
fix is Jesus Christ he always has been
and I think that when he comes back and
he's King will be okay and I think
that's actually great hope like here's
here's some hope put your hope in Jesus
put your hope in somebody who who's
whose rulership and his kingdom will be
good for everybody so that's those are
mine that's my two thoughts
all right you took us out on some hope
now in good conscience I can't send
people to Twitter after a conversation
like this where can people go to find
out a little bit more about you and what
you do ah they can go to my Instagram
Nathan finocchio and or Nathan my
website Nathan finocchio dot CA I'm
Canadian and you know they can hate on
me and if they have any issues if they
have any problems with this program just
send an email to dave rubin at gmail or
i don't have that gmail so yes they can
send it there all right a pleasure
talking to you and hopefully when all
this stuff clears up we'll be able to do
this in person sometime there's a
pleasure Dave thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist there all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell